so thanks for having me it's great being
here thanks to Robert and Daniel for
giving me the opportunity to speak
what we're going to discuss today is
just a general overview to testing I'm
gonna talk about what is testing why do
you need testing it's not gonna be too
technical all right so if you already
have some experience I hope it's not too
boring okay I was planning on doing like
a quick live demo at the end where it
can actually show off how you can test
some small web application which
unfortunately since technical issues we
can't do today but I'll just walk you
through the code and get up real quick
and see to make the best out of it
I guess right quick bit about myself
where am I well when in towns like I
said already I'm not a front-end death
okay mostly a full stack or a front-end
theft's I am NOT to actually have a Java
and c-sharp background and just recently
got started with Ruby so if you see any
code that looks like garbage is not my
natural habitat okay I am tutoring at
the Technical University so I'm helping
out with teaching there coincidentally
in the subjects testing and software
Quality Assurance so you see how this
how this works yeah and I'm a self and a
big fan of testing why do I like testing
my first job was in a testing firm and
yeah I like testing because it liked
protects us from the code from the evil
that is cold okay what I mean by that no
program is kind of hard a lot of people
have written about how software today is
kind of sucks I remember an article I
read that was typed in the coming
software pocalypse was really like oh my
God we're all gonna die problem is soft
us really complex today and that causes
a lot of issues okay what I mean by
software is very complex
quick guessing game for you all what do
you reckon an average car like not
average but luxury car today
like smart car how many lines of code
does the software in that car just the
software that stirs the car in
everything how many lines of code in the
gear
it's gonna be 1 million it's gonna be 10
million or 100 million give me a show of
hands so I know you're not asleep who
thinks it's 1 million okay good one all
right
he thinks it's ten million ten million
lines of code in the car a bunch of
people who thinks it's a hundred million
just one okay well the trick questions
actually 600 million lines of code okay
it's exactly on lines of code for a
freaking car that's what we've come to
complex code means a lot of errors all
right you know it's like you touch some
piece of software and basically breaks
as soon as you're like poking it an
example I always give for critical
software errors is the story of the
arianna anyone has a clue of what Ariana
what the ariana is exactly yeah was a
rocket that was built in 1996 by
European Space Agency and the story
about Ariana's are a sad one they built
this thing they developed it for 10
years cost about 400 million bucks and
it launched it and it went up like four
kilometers and then it blew up because
someone didn't convert some floating's
into improperly and the rocket did like
a flip and it went bang okay
400 million lines of code because of a
teeny whiny error there was almost no
more than 20 years ago
a more recent story maybe you followed
Luber self-driving cars there has been
an issue with one car in the beginning
of August the car basically ran over
petrest
pedestrian like full stop just went
through and they found out well it
registered her well no problem with the
sensor senses but for some reason the
car decided not to stop okay just mine
which is very sad so we have some issues
with software there's a bunch of
problems what can we do to avoid these
issues obviously we do testing okay
so doesn't matter if you talk about cars
or web applications or just small
functions the concepts always the same
you
some components some system and it's
supposed to do something in a way of
like a car is supposed to stuff properly
your web application supposed to display
some values properly this function idea
it's supposed to divide two numbers
calculate the division easy peasy
how do you know if it works well how do
you check if your calculator works you
try it out type in some numbers just
display the correct result if it does so
good if not you found an issue this is
what testing does you take your system
in some state precondition you chuck
some values in there and you check if
what it puts out is correct
that's basically it this is a test okay
what's the issue with this piece of code
yeah so what input would make that fail
yeah if B is zero exactly in any other
language if this was not JavaScript it
would be an issue
this is JavaScript so just puts out
infinity so if you want your code to
behave that way then it's actually
correct um might be a bug in the
JavaScript language I don't know might
be a feature we might argue that yeah so
we got covered what the test is it's
always the same input output on some
system okay what does testing mean now I
said you check if it works by putting
some stuff into it actually I mean it's
kind of kind of wrong actually testing
is the process it says it acts of
executing a program or system with the
intent of finding errors and that's the
important part you don't test to check
if it works you test to check it doesn't
work you reveal errors basically there's
this comic that says compares
programmers or developers to testers and
the program is like I'm making something
that the test is like I'm breaking
something and that's really what this is
about why do you want to break your
stuff because if you break it someone
else doesn't have the opportunity to
write do you find an error you hopefully
will fix it
not planning good reproduction and then
it won't fail in production that's good
we want that why do we want that what
you actually care if you produce work in
software I personally think it's a bit
of our responsibility personal
responsibility as developers we build
stuff for the world to run on okay we
want that stuff to work we don't want to
contribute to the house cave to this
program today okay we want to build nice
things and I hope you all kind of want
to do that if that noble goal doesn't
cut it for you want to save your dignity
and money because errors that live in
the wild are pretty expensive like a
rocket blowing up that costs 400 million
pretty expensive if you find that the
issue spent half an hour testing
something finding least you fixing that
bit cheaper and also especially in the
security scene where you have issues
with security that can cause a lot of
embarrassment if you have problems
security issues or box stuff like that
yeah so in reality combination of both I
think this should make it clear why you
want to test good I got the motivation
covered hopefully now we're going to
talk about the types of errors that you
can reveal with tests the thing is I
said testing is the process of finding
errors okay which errors there's a bunch
of errors can happen many different
different errors we don't have time to
cover them all so we're just gonna talk
about regression tests on regression
errors
what's a regression it's something that
if all if you've developed for more than
a week you've already seen that it's
this situation you develop some
wonderful feature you build it and I
tell you test did you make sure it works
so you try it out try to break it and it
doesn't break all good you say you push
it to production it's fine let it run
there you work on some other stuff three
months later you decide to let's try my
old feature again right just
coincidentally you touch it it breaks
like what the actual that's a regression
you have something that used to work now
it doesn't and everyone's like
what happened that yeah to avoid these
kind of errors you have regression tests
yeah so what do people do in reality to
avoid regressions I've actually worked
with places or seen places where each
time they have a release let's say you
have a release of some piece of spanking
software every six months they would
spend they have had a manual test suite
with several thousand tests and they
would before each release they would
take a month with something like between
15 and 20 testers and those testers
would run a manual regression test suite
for and months out of six months
development time okay so if you have
lots of features lots of stuff to test
regression testing is gonna take a lot
of time we developers we're lazy we
don't want to spend a month because each
time we release it especially in today's
world we have to release fast we can't
really do that
enter automation luckily smart people
have developed a bunch of tools to allow
us to automate this process so you don't
have to each time you change something
manually see if it still works you can
instead write your tests by coding so
you see it here there's some I didn't
know what the framework is basically you
write the test code and that will do
this process of putting stuff in
checking if it works automatically and
the good thing is well you spend some
time developing the test beforehand but
now you can rerun those tests at the
press of a button and you see that here
you don't even have to press something
like the framework just detects if
anything changed if you change your code
it's gonna rerun your test and goes like
this okay so test automation can really
help you avoid these doing the same
thing with testing over and over again
what in an application can you test so
we got covered okay what kind of errors
do we check where we're gonna check them
if you have some application there's
very many ways to or many things to
actually test the most intuitive thing
would be let's assume you have an
application that has this email input
field where people enter the email and
say okay and then at some point they're
gonna get send and registration may or
something like that okay the intuitive
thing maybe would be to have the
automation system really interact with
the application you'd have the web web
thing with the input field and button
and your framework would interact with
that input field type something and
automatically press the button and at
some point it would check some mail
server if an email with the correct
content has arrived what would work but
there's other ways to test your
application you don't always have to
test the whole thing together there's
always a at the whole system end to end
you can also simply take some components
out of that system and test those like
an isolation that for example an
integration test where test components
together or unit tests where you test a
single component for example just up to
make the class that sent mails it gets a
string and it sends mail you test that
why do you do that two things first of
all each of those levels so to speak
reveals different errors again a very
unit test that's very good at uncovering
issues that are related to functionality
some small issue with the component
integration tests much better with
finding issues that occur when different
components don't quite work together as
well as they should
what end-to-end tests imagine these
really do basically what user does so
they're often called acceptance tests
that would detect like stuff like is a
button actually visible because it will
actually try to click the button and it
isn't there well you found that
so good at different things that's the
fury part oh no it's not quite sorry
the other thing with these levels is
that they have equal cut not equal they
have different costs associated with
them unit tests are very easy to write
and they're very quick to run end-to-end
tests not so much they're harder to
write take longer to execute and this is
where testing pyramids gonna come in who
has already seen that before today ring
okay how many times like Daniel how many
times have you seen those in the talk
exactly you're all gonna I'm happy that
I'm the first one to actually show you
see if you attend any tests about
talking at all ever again you're gonna
see this very very popular because it's
really tells you how should you automate
your harsh idea automation test suite
look lots of unit tests a bunch of
integration tests not too many
end-to-end tests so the balance between
cost and risk what kind of issues can
you find how much money do you want want
to spend that's it with fury but LS
there's no life demo instead I whipped
up the quick application that I would
normally how do I get out of full screen
no no it doesn't work in something
control P
come and control shift F and shifting
yeah we got it
I'm not a Mac user in case you haven't
noticed all right so I whipped up a
quick application that I would normally
I provide a test suite and would
normally run that we quite can't do that
so instead I'm going to show you the
application I will show you the tests I
wrote and you just have to imagine that
they actually run okay if you can do
that use your fantasy so let's look at
the application first fair word of
warning I had to come up with an idea
what am I going to build that's easily
testable and demonstrate some concepts
of testing and the only thing my brain
could come up with was let's make an
application where you manage kittens
that fight each other to the death kind
of thing
I don't know so this is not it because
that doesn't work sorry about that
enter right
what isn't gonna oh my god did I mention
a mother Mac user
Jesus what I need to do
don't all right what yeah yeah okay how
their copy command see no no not enter
another hit enter and see and now okay
can i paste something here caps-lock
maybe like that maybe we found a part
through testing like that maybe may pass
it need tacitly HT does it need like an
HTTP in front maybe
kind of press enter.now
I love that [ __ ] alright sorry yes so
alright so right so I made this a
monstrosity you can see you have a list
of kittens alright and it's very simple
you can also edit and delete them let's
have a look at some kittens I don't like
that one I please didn't test it
know what's actually happening I didn't
test it on Safari that's exactly right
okay we'll just have to do it that way
so as you can see you you can put in
some stuff and it should hopefully yeah
so it will update this score that tells
you how much is this kitten is okay and
so what can you test you can do unit
tests or end-to-end tests let's look at
that God not the same thing again we'll
get up how can I do a new tab okay
so I'm gonna just quickly show you what
the unit test could look like all right
for that and like I said you will have
to imagine that they just work right so
this is an angular application it
doesn't really matter that it is just
gonna have look so this what I showed
you that the score that's calculated
that's a perfect example for a thing you
can unit test okay because it's fairly
simple just take some values and puts
out the number so let's look at what the
code look looks like so that's it
doesn't really matter what the syntax
like you have this component the battle
score service well as an effort
calculate battle points that takes a
kitten and returns a number okay
and what does it do then well if the
kittens now there's nothing to return to
return zero otherwise it takes the
attributes of the kitten cuteness speed
blah blah blah and calculates your
battle points easy peasy
so very clear what the function is very
easy to test unit test right this is a
unit a simple simple component simple
function to test now let's have a look
at the test it more stuff still come
move so I have two imaginary pointing so
this is a test file and remember what a
test looks like just none back you have
a component you have some input and you
have some expected result we're gonna
use that here first of all you can see
in like the line fix line 9 we create a
system the thing that we want to test in
this case it's a battle score service
the component we want to test our
calculator whatever and then we have
actual test cases that start with it in
line 1220
let's look at the first one line 12
first of all has a name what does it do
it should return a correct battle score
and then you set up your input
remember the input of the battle service
function was a kittens or a create one
with its attributes
strength and so forth next line after
that is the actual execution of the test
where we take the function and we put
stuff in this is excellent let's do it
part and then we record the result now
the last thing we have to do we compare
the actual result with what we get back
and that's the expect expect the result
that would we actually get with what we
want should be can and similarly we test
if it works for now
easy peasy right normally it's a an
issue of just executing command in this
case ng test and this will run all your
tests automatically and will also watch
your files for changes and if you break
the application you're affected and you
do something bad we will show you well
you have an issue easy peasy
let's have a look at the end-to-end
tests so this is the component a single
component that we can test and go back
to the application something that is
lends itself to an end-to-end test would
be scenarios like does it display the
list in the index correctly or when I
press Delete is it actually removed from
the list or if I edit it in the Edit
field is it actually updated in the
index things like that so multiple views
needs the whole application that would
be an end-to-end test and we're going to
have a look at what an end-to-end test
looks like angular luckily makes it's
fairly easy to set this kind of stuff up
like I said another front end death so
I'm pretty happy and you already noticed
when we look at this app's back end to
end test file it's a bit more involved
right you have stuff like page that
navigate to I mean the concept is the
same you do something and then you have
an expectation and expected result
but you see gets longer involves more
pages for example in line 25 we just
check if we click the button remove it
from the list and you see it's already
getting a bit like longer and needs more
syntax also maintenance is harder we see
that we calculate we
get items by selecting the links in the
actual HTML all right imagine if you
change that up if you give it if you use
CSS selectors and you change your CSS
your tests are going to break that won't
happen with your unit test good how the
hell I'm gonna get to my presentation
chrome where was it yeah it is okay so
that was the practical part sorry again
it didn't work out let's summarize what
we've learned today
first of all programming is its own kind
of hellscape which I hope you don't have
to learn too much but testing can help
you with that
okay we learned about regression tests
why use them and we also talked about
what test automation and test louses so
I hope I didn't give you too much stuff
like okay very risky show of hands who's
kind of like this was a bit too much for
me like I did that who is like that show
of hands okay one two all right too fast
who could follow along nicely and
understood most of stuff okay thank you
and who's like I don't give up okay mine
so that's what a summary if you're
interested to learn more about testing
first of all just send me a message I'm
always happy to help people out like I
said I'm very passionate about testing
let me know what you think let me know
if you have some problems with testing
something specific talk over that and
there's some great books out of software
testing or the art of unit testing and
you can also visit the Ministry of
testing website they've great resources
so that's it from my side you can check
out the slides hosted them with reveal
just gonna have a look at the other
thing what was it remark Jess gotta
check that out and yeah do we have time
for questions
yep thanks